madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue en
direct sur le plateau de la voie est
libre en bourgogne aujourd'hui nous
allons ausculté l'organisation des soins
dans la région les déserts médicaux
ont-ils reculé grâce au pacte territoire
santé grâce aux initiatives des
collectivités locales et des
professionnels de santé eux-mêmes
eh bien nous en discutons jusqu'à 12h20
avec nos invités rémi chaintron bonjour
je vous êtes le président du conseil
général de saône et loire vous avez
notamment initié il y a un an
l'opération installe un médecin points
comme on va en parler
christophe lannelongue bonjour bonjour
vous êtes directeur général de la rs l'
agence régionale de santé c'est la grèce
qui donc organiser l'offre de soins sur
le territoire
guy doussot bonjour je vous êtes le
maire de château chinon vous êtes
confrontés en ce moment à de quelques
difficultés pour faire les questions
médicales avec votre hôpital dentiste
disons douteux et puis départ annoncé de
deux médecins libéraux enfin michel
serein bonjour le médecin et vous avez
créée en 2005 la première maison de
santé en france c'est à saint amand en
puisaye dans la nièvre vous êtes un
farouche partisan à de ces regroupements
vous présidez la fédération des maisons
et des pôles de santé de la région vous
êtes aussi le vice président de la
fédération nationale à la maison je vous
rappelle que vous posez vous pouvez
posez vous même vos questions à nos
invités via twitter hashtag lvl
bourgogne watts r 3 bourgogne ou bien
sur notre site internet google point
france 3 points et fait alors on va
commencer par le constat si vous voulez
peut-être vous monsieur lannelongue
en bourgogne le nombre de généralistes
restent inférieures de 9 % à la moyenne
nationale c'est bien ça c'est tout volta
c'est une situation traditionnel mais la
bourgogne est effectivement une région
plutôt moins favorisés que d'autres mais
très franchement c'est pas ça qui est
l'élément à mon avis majeur du constat
des éléments majeurs du constat c'est le
vieillissement de beaucoup de médecins
est donc une échéance qui se rapproche
et qui doit nous conduire à recruter des
médecins pour faire face aux départs qui
sont simplement liés à l'âge de ses
médecins
il ya un médecin sur 3g vie notamment où
il ya plus de 60 ans en saône et loire
c'est une situation qui inquiète vous en
tant qu'élu re donc à responsable du
département
c'est la raison pour laquelle
effectivement nous avons souhaité venir
en complément du pacte territoire santé
qui a été mis en place par par l'état
par le gouvernement et donc on a
souhaité travailler avec l'agencé
régionale de santé avec l'ordre des
médecins pour mettre en place et bien un
dispositif qui permet d'attirer de
nouveaux médecins puisque comme vous
l'avez dit près d'un tiers d'entre eux
ont plus de 60 ans ils prennent leur
retraite autour de 65 ans en tant que
libéro et donc il faut prévoir
effectivement leur remplacement dont la
détailler tout ça est ce que ça se
ressent directement sur les
professionnels de santé qui sont
remplaçants parle de d'horaires
d'amplitude horaire soit pour le travail
des médecins qui qui font actuellement
en activité s'il en manque à ce point là
oui tout à fait ça se ressent au
quotidien on parle même d' effet domino
c'est à dire que quand il ya un médecin
qui s'en va à la retraite ou pour
raisons de santé aussi il ya une
surcharge de travail pour les médecins
aux alentours et un certain nombre qui
s'en vont parce qu'il ne supporte plus
c'est cette surcharge de travail mon la
lauréat moyenne d'un médecin généraliste
et plus de cinquante sept heures par par
semaine
donc c'est les tâches administratives et
c'est donc le quotidien est bien rempli
et ça se vérifie notamment à château
chinon il ya une question notamment d'un
internaute qui dont le pseudo est joujou
43,47 ce qu'ils nous demandent à la
situation à château chinon comment
allez-vous faire et que ce départ des
deux médecins a annoncé pour janvier
nous allons lancer des fleurs à la
recherche de médecins par
l'intermédiaire d' annonce en ultime
recours peut-être par des chasseurs de
têtes et nous comptons sur la rs pour
nous aider dans cette recherche
vous avez un autre problème vous séance
il l'hôpital alors pour ce qui concerne
l'hôpital
ça va ce sujet donc cela une longue
connaît bien les détails
nous avons un médecin hospitalier qui
est arrivé le 1er octobre un autre qui
doit arriver le 1er décembre et qui pour
faire la liaison avec le sujet précédent
devrait travailler à temps partagé entre
la maison médicale et l'hôpital ce qui
est sans doute d'ailleurs à la source
des difficultés que nous avons avec le
départ des deux médecins libéraux alors
avant de devenir vraiment aux médecins
libéraux à la station peut-être un mot
sur la situation des hôpitaux est
notamment dans la nielle notamment à
château chinon
on a vu aussi des manifestations pour
2,6
est ce que le rôle de ces hôpitaux doit
être vraiment redéfinissez le travail
que vous faites en ce moment mais qui
est parfois mal à créteil balcon prix
alors c'est des hôpitaux qui sont dans
un contexte difficile par clairement
dans la nièvre en matière de démographie
médicale parce que les questions de
démographie nickel se pose pas
simplement sur la médecine de ville
elle se pose aussi à l'hôpital et c'est
donc des hôpitaux qui sont fragilisés
par le fait que c'est parfois pas facile
de remplacer un médecin qui s'en va à la
pâte
par ailleurs c'est des hôpitaux qui joue
un rôle essentiel et notamment dans un
contexte de vieillissement de la
population
car ils sont un point majeur de contact
avec le système de santé pour faire des
diagnostics pour orienter les patients
dans le semo spitalier donc tout le défi
qui nous est lancé c'est d'arriver à
concilier la proximité maintenir
une proximité et un accès proche pour
les personnes et en même temps garantir
une forme de coopération d'intégration
entre les hôpitaux publics de façon à
garantir l'accès à de l' expertise à des
médecins spécialistes dans des bonnes
conditions et pour nous ça passe par de
la coopération entre les hôpitaux de
l'intégration entre de puteaux et la
coopération avec les os il est né les
maisons santé peut-être bien sûr un
c'est à la fois l'idée qu' on doit créer
ce qu'on appelle nous des communautés
hospitalières de territoire dont vont
regrouper plusieurs hôpitaux publics et
qui vont permettre de mieux organiser
les filières de soins de mieux organiser
le recrutement
et puis c'est aussi une autre forme de
relation avec la médecine de ville et de
ce point de vue là les maisons de santé
sont un élément majeur pour faire ce
décloisonnement pour faire cette
nouvelle mode de relation entre la
médecine de ville et l'hôpital et c'est
comme ça qu'on va s'en tirer si on reste
avec des hôpitaux isolé si on reste avec
des hôpitaux isolé donc non attractif
on n'aura pas de médecin et on
n'arrivera pas à répondre aux besoins de
la population
donc c'est une période qui effectivement
très difficile car le système
hospitalier doit évoluer
s'il veut répondre aux besoins amende
oui sauf que sauf qu'il faut faire
attention lorsqu'on parle de ce sujet il
y à des salariés qui sont très inquiets
on avait la rage est stationnaire
on parle de supprimer la cuisine on
parle de supprimer la blanchisserie
il y à 27 miller 2 supplémentaires qui
n'ont pas été réglés et il faut faire
très attention de ne pas traumatiser
encore plus les salariés de cet hôpital
c'est sûr qu'il faut organiser
l'évolution on est à un moment où c'est
pas possible d'avoir dans les différents
hôpitaux de la nièvre différents
systèmes d'information différents
systèmes logistiques différents systèmes
de cuisine il faut mutualiser organisé
en commun pour des questions de kout
pour des questions de coût mais aussi de
qualité
les systèmes d'information ils sont en
retard parce que chacun bricole dans son
coin si les hôpitaux de l'année elles
sont réunis dans une communauté fidèle
de territoire de la nièvre et ont un
système d'information unifié ça
permettra de faciliter le travail des
médecins parce qu on aura des dossiers
patients qui sapent long et puis ce sera
un système de meilleure qualité par
rapport à ce qu'on fait en bricolant
dans des petites piques
séparé mais c'est vrai le maire a raison
de le dire ça ça doit se faire dans le
cadre d'un dialogue social avec un
accompagnement très fort des agents et
bon voilà il est sinon c'est pas ce sera
pas acceptée ce sera je dirais enfin une
impasse donc c'est une transformation
nécessaire que la mutualisation
notamment des fonctions logistiques ou
des systèmes d'information mais ça doit
se faire d'une manière effectivement
dialogue est organisé et puis dans la
durée par rapport aux relations entre
l'hôpital et le milieu ambulatoire donc
si la première maison de santé en france
étaient en bourgogne les professionnels
de santé de premier recours en crée
aussi les premiers groupements de
professionnels de santé qui justement
travail de façon rapprochée avec les
hôpitaux de territoire pour fluidifier
le parcours de santé de la personne pour
favoriser l'accès aux soins est aussi de
ce fait là pour favoriser la ville
l'hôpital de proximité pour que les
patients aient confiance aux puissent y
accéder et la problématique du système
d'information est une des problématiques
sur lesquelles nous travaillons sur le
lait transmission sécurisée des
informations en amont avant l'hôpital à
la sortie de l'hôpital
et donc c'est comprendre professionnels
de santé qui sont surtout présents sur
bonne un peu sur la côte d'or mais aussi
se déploie sur sur la nièvre sur l'yonne
aussi permettent en fait une meilleur
temps
recours à l'hospitalisation une
meilleure sortie d'hospitalisation
éviter les ré hospitalisations rapide
donc tout ça ça permet aussi d'améliorer
à la fois le lien avec l'hôpital la
qualité de l'hospitalisation la
diminution des décès jours et de ce fait
la sarre en l'hôpital aussi plus lisible
et plus pratique pour l'usagé local
on va continuer par fm et une petite
parenthèse sur l'origine du problème
parce qu'on a quand même quelques
questions notamment là dessus comment on
explique finalement cette carence de
médecins dans certaines zones notamment
peut-être une question de politique là
d'un internaute qui nous demandent la
désertification des services publics des
pompes à essence de la culture de l'art
et des infrastructures
est-ce que ça entraîne pas forcément
aussi une désertification médicale ça va
dans la même logique on va dire on a un
problème dans ce pays c'est la mauvaise
répartition finalement des médecins
généralistes puisqu'il ya suffisamment
de médecins généralistes actuellement
sur le territoire français pour les 64
65 millions de français puisqu'il ya
soixante mille médecins généralistes
brême c'est un problème de répartition
entre des régions comme la région paca
où il ya un médecin pour 300 patients et
d'autres endroits en milieu rural où il
ya un médecin généraliste pour 3000
patients donc nous ce qu'on essaye de
faire et notamment nous en tant que élus
locaux c'est à dire on se sait pas dans
nos compétences
la santé cité de compétence de l'état
mais nous avons en compétences la
solidarité territoriale et surtout
l'aménagement du territoire et c'est un
service essentiel
l'offre de soins donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle on essaye de corriger ce
déficit en meuse en mettant en place des
mesures incitatives pour faire venir
effectivement de nouveaux médecins ou
deux ans en saône et loire par exemple
et notamment avec des maisons de santé
parce que le regroupement est
essentielle pour attirer des jeunes
médecins
les médecins d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas
les médecins d'hier il aspire à une
autre qualité de vie c'est bien normal
monsieur le docteur serein rappelait
déjà le nombre d'heures que que fait
un médecin de façon hebdomadaire et donc
il veut pouvoir être remplacé donc il
veut travailler avec d'autres collègues
et donc non ce n'est pas on est alors le
premier département se passe au contrôle
de monsieur lannelongue en termes de
nombre de maisons de santé puisque la
saône et loire on a actuellement 21e sur
les trente neuf que compte la bourgogne
comme la région bourgogne est celle qui
est la mieux dotée en france et donc on
en est le projet département aux france
et on a encore une dizaine de projets en
gestation on voit bien aussi l'intérêt
que kim est aussi les médecins la
profession parce que maison de santé ça
se fait d'abord avec des médecins et des
professionnels en place mais aussi 10
infirmiers infirmières mais aussi
d'autres professionnels de santé dans
d'autres disciplines
et puis la volonté aussi des élus locaux
de le faire pour mettre en place des
projets immobiliers vous donnez à part
le docteur je voudrais compléter la
question avec celle qui passe en ce
moment sur notre antenne mais douch que
sont les politiques ça s'adresse cette
politique mais aussi à vous monsieur là
non pour revaloriser aussi la fonction
de médecin généraliste et un manque
d'enseignants maître de stage la non
reconnaissance des métiers est ce que
tout ça ce sont des réalités
c'est vrai que la médecine générale a
été on va dire tardivement reconnu et ça
fera peut-être plus tardif que dans
l'ensemble des autres pays comparables
ça faisait très longtemps en angleterre
aux pays bas en allemagne et même aux
états unis qu'on avait pris conscience
que au fond le premier maillon du
système de santé le médecin généraliste
comme on dit chez nous le médecin
traitant
il est essentiel pour garantir une bonne
orientation des passions dans le système
de soins pour garantir une prise en
charge globale cohérente un
accompagnement et donc peut-être qu'en
france on avait une vision peut-être un
peu plus comment dire focaliser sur les
spécialités autre que la médecine
générale est donc cet ep aussi faut le
dire qu'ils sont très bien payés et
cette évolution on la vit avec retard
mais on la vit vraiment maintenant c'est
à dire que si on regarde les choses sur
cinq à dix ans alors les changements
sont considérables en termes de
reconnaissance de la place de la
médecine générale dans les études il ya
en bourgogne aujourd'hui 28 maître de
stage il ya 100% aujourd'hui des
étudiants de deuxième cycle
qui font un stage en médecine générale
c'était 70 % il ya encore un an
il ya le fait qu'il ya la moitié des 200
internes
il ya 210 interne actuellement à la fac
de dijon il y en a deux la moitié qui
sont des internes en formation de
médecine générale
je crois que on rattrape peu à peu se
envoyèrent retard mais je voudrais
insister sur un point c'est essentiel
que ces jeunes professionnels en
formation il soit mis le plus vite
possible au contact des réalités
professionnelles futures
parce que la médecine générale donc je
pars tout contrôle des acteurs sol
c'est un très beau métier et quand on
met les jeunes en situation de découvrir
ce métier mais généralement ils ont une
très forte adhésion
parce que c'est un métier extrêmement
épanouissant à bâle et respire un
médecin je trouvais cette première
engagement je vois dit pas qu'il est
terré part ça je me devais être de
mettre tous les étudiants en stage chez
nous et ça alors on voit que dans
certaines régions ça commence à se faire
avec 100 % des étudiants qui nous font
vivre dans des actuaires on est à 100%
mais c'est vrai aussi que il faut qu'on
arrive maintenant à diversifier ses
lieux d'achat qu'on est à 100% mais avec
des sages qui sont encore un peu trop
concentrés autour de dijon pour dire
clairement les choses
docteur sera sport ce sujet c'était un
sujet très vaste
historiquement donc le système de santé
actuel dont on est très fiers a été
essentiellement basée sur l'hôpital
c'est l'occasion de rappeler qu on a à
peu près 40% de lits d'hôpitaux en plus
que les autres pays occidentaux ce qui a
un impact sur les économies de santé non
négligeable et sur le recours au système
de santé aussi très particulier des
français
ensuite beaucoup de formation de
spécialistes reconnaissance des
spécialistes et la reconnaissance de la
médecine générale très tardive donc
avait effectivement avec peu de moyens
et on peut dire aussi que les autorités
ont pas accompagner le changement c'est
à dire que à l'heure actuelle peu de
médecins ont donné un temps de
secrétariat
il n'y a pas eu d' accompagnement sur
l'évolution des nouvelles technologies
sur le l'outil informatique on a laissé
créé tout un tas de logiciels différents
si bien qu'il ya une dispersion et puis
l'autre élément c'est que
comme dit monsieur lannelongue la
formation initiale des étudiants se fait
très proche de la faculté et donc pour
des territoires comme la nièvre on se
sent vraiment très en marge de dijon est
un des défis est ce que ce que nous nous
réfléchissons c'est d'essayer de deux
d'améliorer la formation au plus proche
des territoires c'est à dire essayer de
développer une vraie vie entre les
internes qui sont à l'hôpital de nevers
entre les intérêts qui sont en stage
dans les mets dans les territoires
avaient mis en place vous à l'internât
un internat rural de manière à ce que
les internes qui découvre le bonheur de
la médecine générale comme dirait
monsieur l'annoncé à s'épanouissant de
voir la diversité de notre activité qui
va de la conception de la vie jusqu'à
jusqu'aux soins palliatifs jusqu'à
jusqu'à la mort c'est aussi tout un tas
de gestes techniques c'est la
reconnaissance de nos patients qui nous
renvoie cette confiance ces arbres
généalogiques entier que l'on soigne
delà de l'arrière-grand-mère jusqu'aux
petits enfants arrière petits enfants
qui avec tous les aléas de la vie
et puis le soir il se retrouver tout
seul à la maison de santé et donc l'as
l'émotion était plutôt négative même si
on les implique dans la vie culturelle
du village parce que nos villages notre
campagne ce débat justement contre ces
problèmes de désertification de ce qui
se passe plein de choses
donc ça nous le faire découvrir et là
avec l'internât on accueille deux
internes et deux externes donc à cheval
sur deux de maison de santé
fatalement donc saint-amand refuser un
logement qui est mis à disposition par
la commune de saint-amand et nous
accueillons aussi des étudiants de la
maison de santé de dos un sauveur qui
est l'autre côté de la frontière
après le net à bien des domaines et du
coup il ya une vraie dynamique se crée
entre entre les jeunes et les
remplaçants qui viennent ou remplacer
rencontre ces jeunes donc il ya une
vraie dynamique collectif et on commence
à voir émerger justement sur le
territoire des jeunes qui ont envie de
s'installer parce qu'ils savent qu'ils
seront pas qu'ils ne seront pas isolé et
leur rôle d'écoulement de professionnels
de santé ou des pôles de santé
territoriaux comme le rappelle l' agence
régionale de santé de bourgogne dans son
référentiel d exercice coordonné
il ya aussi une dynamique de vie de
rencontres qui fait que ont créé des
groupes de pairs ont fait des formations
interprofessionnel sur nos
territoire si bien que les jeunes auront
un peu moins peur de s'installer parce
que il ya les maisons de santé
ils y allaient pour ceux qui exercent de
façon isolée ils peuvent rencontrer les
médecins en maison de santé et puis les
groupes de pairs qui permettent aussi de
lutter contre l' isolement et les
formations interprofessionnel qui permet
justement de développer ceux auxquels je
voulais dire initialement c'est qu'on
est confronté à un changement du système
de santé
avant on allait voir le docteur pour pas
mourir maintenant on est confronté à des
maladies chroniques
même le cancer devient une maladie
chronique dont il faut faire face à ces
maladies chroniques à la poly pathologie
est donc là c'est très difficile pour un
professionnel isolé de d'accompagner ces
personnes et l'autre élément c'est qu'on
se recentre aussi sur le patient avec la
loi sur le patient qu'on met au coeur du
système de santé
et ça c'est vraiment le coeur de métier
de des maisons de santé des complaintes
procès n de santé s'est essayé de donner
aux patients toute son autonomie son
envie de participer à la prise en charge
alors comme l'a dit à nos
téléspectateurs désertification qu'elle
touche aussi les vilains parfois
d'ailleurs on voit des maisons santé en
ville notamment mais pour rebondir sur
ce que disait le médecin monsieur bousso
sanaa ben ça ne suffit pas finalement
une maison sans qu'elle en avait une
ça dépend comment elles sont conçues les
maisons de santé notamment celles de
château chinon
il ya eu une mutualisation a minima
c'est à dire uniquement pour le ménage
l'électricité etc
or je voudrais sortir location voire en
avril 2013 avait été signé un contrat
territorial un contrat pluriannuel
d'objectifs et de moyens qui prévoyait
justement que les médecins de cette fine
on puisse former des jeunes médecins ou
des remplaçants un studio avait même été
prévus qui n'est pas encore qui n'a pas
été construit mes pots à lait dans le
même sens que vous venez de dire est à
mon sens il faut que c'est ça peut pas
être uniquement
comment dire un accueil immobilier et
c'est peut-être ça qui a fait des fois
c'est tout sinon car ça l'est uniquement
que cela alors il y a dès jeudi à dire
qu'il ya des paramédicaux qui sont dans
cette maison santé qui je travaille très
très bien un orthophoniste a été recruté
un kiné a été recrutée donc eux ils ont
fait l'engagement qui était dans ce
contrat
je n'ai pas conscience que les médecins
il fait le même travail réponse alors
moi je veux enfin partager ce que vient
de dire le maire sait c'est ça a été
pour nous une surprise et je dise
franchement une forte déception de voir
cette maison de santé où il y avait
quatre médecins début 2013
voir les médecins disparaître et
finalement si on ne fait rien on 1er
janvier 2015 un drap 0 et ça a été une
forte déception parce que je partage ce
qu'a dit le président chanteront ou
docteur serein c'est à dire que
l'exercice en équipe le travail en
équipe
c'est ça qui a à la fois attractif pour
les jeunes professionnels et c'est ce
qui est aussi on va dire une condition
pour l'amélioration de la prise en
charge des patients ça qu'on soigne
mieux parce qu'on travaillait en équipe
donc je suis effectivement surpris de
voir qu à château chinon on n'a pas
réussi à faire prendre la mayonnaise
comme on nie pas c'est pas normal que ce
soit pas le premier jour qu'on travaille
bien ensemble
une maison de santé c'est des habitudes
qui vont se créer peu à peu et de mon
point de vue c'est est pas normal qu au
début ce soit comme l'a dit le maire un
rassemblement impôts immobiliers de
copropriétaires on va dire par où deux
colocataires
mais ce qui effectivement décevant c'est
que ça n'a pas évolué favorablement dans
le sens de la mise en oeuvre d'un projet
de santé bon les causes sont diverses et
variées ce qu'il faut c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on en sorte et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on est un peu à la
croisée des chemins il y a des solutions
transitoires qu'on va essayer de
construire avec avec le maire le
président la communauté de communes mais
c'est la même personne qui est en face
de moi mais il ya surtout à réfléchir
sur le moyen terme sa direction de six
mois à un an
est ce que on a la possibilité à château
chinon de faire venir des jeunes
médecins
maintenant qui a plus rien ou est ce que
il faut créer un centre de santé avec la
médecine salariée qui est finalement
moins exigeante pour les jeunes
professionnels sur internet écouter
voilà le choix pour moi c'est moi je
suis favorable au à l'installation en
libéral et toute la politique de
l'agencé de promouvoir des maisons de
santé ou l'exercice est un exercice
libéral mais dans les cas où on a pu la
le minimum
de présence médicale pour créer un cadre
attractif pour les joueurs laver au nord
de l'yonne adoma actuellement mais c'est
la même situation dans des endroits
comme demain où on a pas on n'a plus le
médecin
là c'est impossible d'attirer des jeunes
parce qu'on ne peut pas créer ce qu'a
dit docteur serein c'est à dire l'esprit
d'équipé et dans ces endroits là et
seulement dans ces endroits
par exception on peut envisager étudier
le recours à un centre de santé avec des
médecins salariés comme à domagné par
l'agonie d'un message de l'initiative de
la rs et des professionnels de santé
ça ne peut pas être mis à la charge des
collectivités je ne crois pas personne
alors c'est effectivement attendre de
narnia le président chain tron a dit
tout à l'heure que les progrès c'est
d'abord la capacité de travail en commun
des élus des professionnels de la rs et
l'assurance maladie comment donc les
progrès c'est d'abord le fait que tous
les acteurs travaillent de manière
cohérente suis un peu confus mais
d'abord je rappelle 57 eur 2 en moyenne
de temps de travail hebdomadaire on
espère transformer sans salarié le
nombre de médecins qu'il faudrait pour
remplacer des médecins libéraux par
rapport à ça ce que ce que ce que je
ferais bien comme proposition c'est
peut-être aussi de vue le partenariat
que nous avons entre la fédération la rs
et les élus c'est pourquoi pas de faire
un laboratoire de château chinon pour
essayer aussi de moderniser d'avoir une
réactivité par rapport à 7 à cette
problématique parce que dans la loi il y
avait l'article 51 qui était qui
permettait de faire des expérimentations
pour justement aider dans les
territoires difficiles où les médecins
étaient isolés de nouvelles fonctions
pour d'autres professionnels de santé
pour les soulage etc
mais il n'y a jamais eu de moyens qui
ont été mis en place derrière et l'autre
l'autre élément sur lequel je voulais
revenir c'est que une maison de santé
voilà ils les équipes à sont toutes à
des niveaux différents et il faut savoir
les accompagner leur donner des moyens
et là je pense que vu l'urgence la
nécessité peut être con pour essayer de
travailler sur des moyens
supplémentaires de manière que ce soit
du salariat ou du
du libéral mais essayer de faire un
laboratoire parce que je pense que ce
qui arrive à château chinon ça va
arriver où c'est déjà arrivé à d'autres
endroits essayer de voir comment on
pourrait innover pour que le temps
médical soit vraiment du temps médical
et non pas du temps administratif ou du
et peut-être trouvé des assistantes au
médecin qui lui ferait gagner du temps
sur son temps de consultation moderniser
l'exercice
et là je pense qu'on attirera des jeunes
question alors vous vous chercher à les
attirer les jeunes il ya un plan
national a quand même qui a été mise en
place notant par marisol touraine avec
des contrats d'engagement de service
public pas ils ont pour attirer les
jeunes là dans des zones les plus
déficitaires voilà et rouen plus manour
on ne fait pas de distinction entre les
zones déficitaires et celles qui sont
plus déficitaires toutes les zones sont
déficitaires et même les villes et les
villes moyennes aujourd'hui souffrent du
manque de généralistes donc mais ça a
été dit tout à l'heure et il faut faire
découvrir la médecine générale et
notamment la médecine générale pas
forcément que autour de dijon
je m'explique aujourd'hui les jeunes qui
sont étudiants bien évidemment quand ils
cherchent un lieu de stage ils le
cherchent là autour de la fac de dijon
que ce qu'ils habitent à dijon pour
leurs études et donc nous ce qu'on
essaye de faire en saône et loire est la
conséquence de cela c'est que la moitié
des nouveaux médecins qui s'installent
en bourgogne s'installe en côte d'or
autour de dijon
donc pour contrer commencent à faire
leur vie et pour contrecarrer cela eh
bien nous déjà nous essayons d'attirer
ces étudiants en gommant des difficultés
et de logement et de transport ça veut
dire en disait dans leur hébergement
financièrement financièrement déjà pour
les stagiaires à la fois d'hébergement
et aux transports
deuxième chose effectivement vous avez
parlé des bourses s'agissant des
d'émettre des futurs médecins qui ont
choisi médecine générale en spécialité
puisque c'est une spécialité
ce ça la revalorisation aussi de cette
fonction est bien pendant leurs trois
dernières années on leur propose de
passer un contrat avec nous et on leur
finance leurs trois dernières années
d'études à hauteur de 1000 euros par
mois et en contrepartie ils s'engagent à
la fin de leurs études à venir
s'installer en saône et moi s'ils ne
font pas dire en bourse aidé a pour
l'instant on a déjà signé
six bourses je mets ça on a déjà on fait
également des chèques installations
c'est à dire alors là c'est pas
forcément des jeunes mettre ses médecins
ça peut être d'ailleurs des des médecins
sur une seconde vie vous avez des
médecins qui ont travaillé dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique notamment
dernièrement j'en ai rencontré un et qui
rusent d'ailleurs à l'étranger était
revenu il a dit moi j'ai envie de finir
ma carrière en tant que médecin
généraliste c'était mon premier métier
j'ai trouvé ça formidable et puis j'ai
plus envie de l'industrie etc
donc je veux revenir il a 60 ans il va
venir exercer cinq ans en saône et loire
est bien très bien on lui on l'aide à
s'installer en saône et loire notamment
pour payer une petite partie qui chacun
fasse en de 5000 euros pour son matériel
on vient d'ailleurs de renforcer le
dispositif en direction des
ophtalmologistes ça c'est un vrai dire
on manque énormément pour avoir un rendu
noir on est beaucoup beaucoup de temps
donc la ronde double led l'aide du
conseil général
mais voilà c'est important c'est de leur
faire découvrir l'exercice et ce beau
très beau département là bas on a
beaucoup parlé de chasseurs sur ce
magnifique mais pour la saône et loire
ce très beau département et on va mettre
en place et on a mis en place également
en faire de communication des bugs
découverts
allez on fait pour leur faire découvrir
le département comptant jamais tâche au
fonds va continuer à parler de tout ça
mais là on va se faire en quelques
minutes parce qu'il est midi pour
prendre connaissance de l'actualité
c'est avec emmanuel personnes là tout de
suite